we're addicted to technology and
everything that makes it fun but more
and more we're paying a price for all
this tech in our lives and that price is
our privacy I mean after all we're under
constant surveillance and I don't just
mean the NSA even though we know they're
keeping tabs I mean there's a camera on
us nearly all of the time whether it's
that security surveillance camera on
your street corner or that phone we'd
love to take selfies with over the next
few weeks aj+ is going to tackle
surveillance what it's been what it is
now and what it could become and we'll
give you a rewind on NSA bulk
surveillance in fact in 2005 the New
York Times revealed that the National
Security Agency was spying on thousands
of Americans we'll take a peek at some
traditional spying methods in the 1960s
the US government started a program
called COINTELPRO or the
counterintelligence program and some new
strategies being used now got a cell
phone well that's enough to make you a
target of police surveillance in the
u.s. we're gonna ask why cops are
allowed to use surveillance tech
originally made for the military
stingray is a device that simulates a
cell phone tower and it can disrupt and
reroute your connection then you'll hear
from some folks who have fought and
continue to fight against all of this so
join aj+ as we punch up and break down
surveillance